hello everyone glad to be here it's
always a pleasure to come back to
stanford i studied here 95 96
but i've been here so often that it
continues to feel like home
i'm going to talk a little bit about
india and then draw
the associated parallels of what's
happening here as well
before i do that richard wanted me to
introduce my company in this age briefly
we are
an indo-us venture fund
uh we are a seeds early stage venture
fund typically series 8 sometimes series
b
about 150 million dollar
fund and we invest
out of uh
startups both in india as well as in the
us
now
what's going on with india
i wanted to give you a perspective of
what has happened and then from that
extract out to
uh what could happen in the future
now first of all look backwards
now this is a landscape view of the last
15 plus years
and if you look at the time period 2007
to 2009
uh
there was a moment of exuberance when
people said oh my gosh this is where we
should be let's pour a lot of money into
india and they did and that was soon
followed by a lot of depression
about 30 plus billion dollars went into
infrastructure
i.t and it enabled services
and
not very satisfactory there are only
about 140 some exits uh mostly m a out
of 1500 some companies that were
invested in so by and large
one can imagine that this was a somewhat
uh
bad time for vcs and private equity
players
now
the thing that happens in many of these
markets is to say
maybe we should incubate companies
innovation through incubation is the way
to go
so
governments throughout the world start
pouring money into you know incubators
and lo behold a lot of incubators came
along and why do incubators happen
the notion is well we can create an
innovation factory right we can put some
financing structure uh
provide uh infrastructure governance a
team maybe to
manage the inflow some networking a
bunch of advisory services mentors and
lo behold you think there's a factory
people apply they get vetted they get
funding and you wonder okay magic is
going to happen at the end of that and
we're going to get
huge numbers of companies going public
so india did that as well uh we have 200
some odd incubators now in india spread
out through
uh not only large cities but small and
medium cities as well
a lot of these were put out at
universities
and typically computer science
departments mechanical engineering
or sometimes you know creatively an
innovation department
and typically uh
an incubatee company would get about
thousand square feet of space maybe they
would get funding for two and a half
three years
and
then they would leave
but the story of triumph from incubators
has been relatively poor
it's very difficult it turns out that
you have large numbers of people come in
and say
please
come up with magical ideas and create
the new world
then
we prayed a lot and we got some angels
right so the angels came from above
and
in india there were
a set of people who
had been educated in a variety of
institutions not only the famous ones
the iits the ims but also
a host of other institutions india is
lucky to have a lot of engineering
colleges
and
many of these then went abroad and
studied again at
the mits the stanfords of the world
and then they worked abroad as well so a
significant number worked
and they now started to get gray hair
and became older and wiser
and now these people
with a fair amount of money decided that
they were going to make a difference so
they started playing they created angel
networks they organized themselves at
the mumbai angels the chennai angels the
india angel network etc and they started
plowing money in
now
they started investing in things they
knew about so typically
in science and engineering using their
business focus in i.t and i.t enabled
services
into telecom media entertainment
e-commerce now these are people who
are
have a feel for what is possible they
often have come here worked in an ebay
worked at an oracle they have a sense
for the market play here and so they are
putting in their money where their
experience lies so
there they have a sense for what is
traction
how should you look at you know
gaining customers versus gaining revenue
in the earlier type of investment that
we had in india what used to happen was
there was a lot of focus on
get to the money get to revenue
now that kind of a focus what it does is
it forces the entrepreneur to focus too
narrowly on outcomes and not broadly
enough on the platform the enabling
environment and to be able to get the
community going so that focus on a
short-term run to revenue is often
possible in services now india as you
know
is the world's leader in i.t services
two million plus indians know a variety
of languages
and in many ways indians dominate this
market globally
and
that a lot of that strength comes from
the way it's done out of india
but
services based companies have
cash on hand they take a contract money
is there on hand and usually they're
quite profitable so gross margins can be
30 40 percent
so
companies are often quite rich so
billion dollar multi-billion dollar
companies like infosys cognizant etc
were created and that set the framework
for maybe you ought to look at indian
companies as revenue generating
companies versus value generating
companies right so unfortunately that
colored a lot of the early investments
as let's invest in companies which will
make running money right away right
the atm for services we will
these angels on the other hand came in
with a somewhat broader view of creating
value and maybe going after a broad
market share of things
so now
what happened in a broad period up to
out of all the investments that were
done
the exits were relatively few
only a few managed to put in
to get their money out
right so 10 20 returns or a lot of you
know five year time frame but most of
them didn't most of them did not make
money at all
and that is the sad story this is true
of venture capital broadly by the way
this is true of the venture capital even
in the us
uh over the last 10 15 years
venture capital has not made much money
and the reality is we hear of all the
stories of
things have gone public m a this google
has bought that etc but all said and
done we don't hear of the many that
don't survive who don't get the
subsequent rounds and are wiped out
so investors
into india were cautious but at the same
time continue to be interested
indian private equity is disappointed in
the last few years but in lpc india is a
destination with huge potential
another one says while the current
sentiment is negative india continues to
be structurally attractive because its
long-term domestic consumption and cost
efficient export base is instead intact
the enthusiasm for india has waned but
there are many lps who look at india as
a must-have for their portfolios in the
long run
the question is why do they have such
sentiments
india
is a very significant part of the world
population as you all know
and getting bigger
it's also a very large economy if you
measure it on a purchasing power parity
basis it's the third largest in the
world
on a
global
gdp basis it's probably eighth or so in
the world
still a very important country which has
overall underperformed its
competence or capabilities
now out of all this what does the
entrepreneur think well let's see
the entrepreneurs thinks that these are
the things which work there is global
expertise i can hire the people i need
starting a business is less messy than
it used to be
and
by the way entrepreneurship is actually
being celebrated because we've had a few
successes a few indian billionaires
what is missing
there's a lack of an indian flavor of
entrepreneurship that is
there is an american version and it
everyone thinks okay i can create the
silicon valley in bangalore and is that
the way to go and it turns out that's
not that easy
there's not that coherent in angel and
advisor ecosystem which grooms or
provides a runway on how to get to
success
and indian buyers both for the software
that is created as well as the exit is
are relatively immature so indian
companies in general hate to buy
software literally they think software
should be free right the air we breathe
the software that we get should be free
other challenges
india has been unpredictable in the rule
of law which
for instance you want to start a company
you
go to the registrar of companies there's
a hassle you want to
rent a building there's a hassle etc so
a lot of hurdles in the way of setup
and relatively poor support from
government and scaling issues
once you get to be a certain size in
terms of hiring firing etc so
readjusting a company
but the good news is high net worth
individuals are putting in money a lot
of hangouts startup hangouts
occur in india and it is now cool to be
an entrepreneur it used to be that if
you told your dad or mom i want to be an
entrepreneur
they might faint he might have to call
the doctor they'd say why don't you join
a good company like infosys what's wrong
with you you after all you need to get
married kind of thing luckily
that kind of issue has gone away and
people are willing to say oh interesting
what are you going to do
now what is the visa perspective from a
vc
there's a mind shift from it services to
creating far more value
there is booming mobile adoption and
we'll go into that in more detail and
m-commerce is catching on very
fast unfortunately
indian entrepreneurs think that they
need to be valid at silicon valley
levels so there's an unreasonable
expectation of valuation someone starts
a company and he says four of us are us
returned naturally you should give us an
8 million dollar pre-money valuation and
he said wait a minute
what is it what exactly are you doing
which deserves that they said that
doesn't matter i've got a cool name and
i've registered the url
right there's a
there's an ecosystem for valley creation
uh
i'm sorry that doesn't exist and the
india exit options are very poor so
often you're looking at okay is there
are there other players who are going to
buy us out
challenges companies are still losing
money now there's scaling to lend to get
the land grab in the many
ecosystems that exist in india and
that's quite a challenge fulfillment and
logistics are very poor especially in
the hinterland
india is about a third of the size of
the u.s
widely distributed 600 000 some villages
so india is still a challenge to get
around
but what is changing big private equity
and vc players are in the game tier two
cities are adopting e-commerce and
indian startups are starting to take on
giants so the game is starting to get
interesting
from the vc perspective
in many ways vcs are now quite bullish
quite positive about the india game but
they are unhappy 24 hours a day that
comes with being a vc as well
so
what are they grumble about there's a
lack of exits
less than expected returns quality of
gps competition from other markets
regulatory issues the slowing uh down of
the indian economy and the economic
slowdown in general and political
instability so there are many things on
their minds and reasonably so right and
these are all things that that should
concern them
okay
but
as uh sherlock holmes would say
watson the game's a foot
not a word onto into your clothes and
come
and literally the game is changing just
as we think that
things are bad
the darkest r is indeed before the dawn
so let me show you what the dawn looks
like
let me talk to you about a magical
couple
this is ganesha and meena krishnan
and
this couple has done amazing things over
the last 15 plus years first they had a
company called customer asset that they
uh sold subsequently they started tutor
vista for a hundred thousand dollars
tutor vista is the business of
let us give you a tutor online that can
be used remotely so let's say a student
here has got a
struggling in math
uh signs up with tutor vista and lo
behold that person that student in
mountain view has a teacher from india
who says okay let me show you how to do
calculus right so
they set this up essentially taking the
i.t services model which is doing
software for big companies into doing
training educational training for the
world
quite successful sold to pearson for a
couple hundred million dollars
they are active angel investors and 25
startups and you know their portfolio is
worth well over 300 million
the things that they do ganesh is the
master strategist he has a big
perspective and uh mina is the one who
brings the operational focus
uh on getting things done
within their portfolio they now have
portia medical which intends to be the
world's india's largest healthcare
company it's already present with 25 000
home visits thousand plus employees
and look at the backers behind each one
of these things
homeland is intending to look at
interior design solutions
is uh
said to
essentially be an educational provider
blue stone is for fashion jewelry in
india there is a gentleman by name of
ratan tata
tata is famous for
some of you might know the nano car
the tata nano but beyond that tata is
known to be india's foremost business
house and an amazing uh you know
amazingly ethical and uh an outstanding
player in this field
and he came and saw what these guys had
in terms of
selling jewelry online now the indian
tradition of buying jewelry is to go to
these jewelry shops and they would lay
out all the possibilities and people
would buy india is the largest buyer of
gold for instance
as a consequence
these
these merchants would have their ways
open and that had a lot of consequences
it's difficult in india to navigate you
know urban traffic to get to the place
that you want to be able to browse at
will etc
and the notion is
let me show you how to do it online and
people will come and deliver it for you
at home
in india actually a lot of things work
that way so let's say i wanted to buy a
car in india i would call up the
car dealer and say i would like to test
the car the car would come to my house i
would take it for a ride and then decide
that i want to buy it and i would do all
the paperwork at home
so
a lot of these things happen
in terms of a service-based economy
which is uh you know customer-centric
and finally big basket which focuses on
e-commerce to the home
let me talk to you about another giant
this company in moby
started off with two founders
looking at mkoj which is
creating an imitation of google for
searching
codes means search in hindi
they then get a little bit of funding
from mumbai angels so from
the
investors see
the entrepreneurs with a credible
background
they now start giving some funding
the company proceeds and now the valley
network which as you know has got very
strong indian connections starts to get
involved so sharepoint ventures is uh
run is ram sriram who is the first
investor into google and then kleiner
perkins they get into the game they put
some money in
now the advantage of these kinds of
investors is they've seen the play
they know that it takes you need to
invest and you need to be patient and
you need to need to take risk
so you can see that the company then
starts to try other things they get into
europe they get into south africa etc
the same vc's now reinvest they put more
money in and launch into the u.s market
revenues are growing but sales are also
i mean
losses are also increasing
they now go into acquisition buy
something up
now at this point
obviously due to the performance of the
company the credibility of the the
entrepreneurs
as well as the vcs are involved now big
players like softbank get in so they put
in a couple hundred million
right
sales are continuing to grow up uh to go
up
losses are increasing but at the same
time more acquisitions are happening
and now as as they proceed through this
they now have one of the largest mobile
advertising environments in the world
comparable to facebook
they
do about a billion uh they're attend to
about a billion customers
focusing on customer experience on
mobile drive strongly driven by data
analytics and they have name name plated
customers for it so very large play
there
so what's happening overall
india is playing for what i would call
the new market economy
this new our market economy i'm going to
talk about a little bit more in detail
but let me set up the background here
india is the second largest network in
the world
hyper competitive and extremely
affordable
if you have been to india you'll see
that cell phone rates and data
roaming rates are ridiculously cheap
probably
1 20th of the pricing here
right
third largest set of internet consumers
in the world and basically what indians
have done is they've bypassed desktop
and the web page to to jump directly
into mobile
the first experience for most
indians is of a phone
which magically does things for them
so a farmer's kid
might
use the phone to find out okay should i
go into the
city to find a job
or to inquire about you know goods and
services
i remember when i was young
30 plus years back
it used to be india had such little
such a poor telephonic network that
the dad used to
uh say
this family phone is now
will be the property of my eldest son
because he's my favorite son
and that is written into the will
and the reason was it was impossible to
get a phone in india only the government
manufacturer made it and
typically the weight was six to eight
years to get a phone
luckily all of that has changed with
cellular so you can look at the land
lines is about 28 million the mobile
phones are 800 plus million
so a complete change in the way in which
indians think of a phone now everyone
has a phone the other day at dinner at
with with richard and his and his
colleagues
i was saying that
it's likely that today in india you go
to
islam there's no roof
there's no water
there's no food there's no job but for
sure that person has got a cell phone
right
so
some of the most advanced technology
in the midst of a lot of poverty
now india
is
still about 60 plus percent rural all
the green is
rural india in about 600 plus thousand
villages and this is urban and
semi-urban india
now think of all of these starting to
consume in a world
that consists of the three c's of the
market new market economy cloud
connectivity and consumption now what
does this do first let's talk about
connectivity i told you india is now
connected
connected not just in terms of networks
but connected in terms of devices
so now you have
a very large number of indians having
access to some device which has the
ability to extract intelligence
right so
smartphones feature phones tablets
phablets you name it
out of this connectivity now comes
consumption of a variety of things and
i'll show you low end as well as higher
in consumption shortly but this
connectivity enables consumption of
products and services
this consumption then fuels or demands
new services from the cloud so new
players get in and say oh but i could
create that this could happen etc this
cloud then provides
provides services which foster increased
connectivity people say oh i should buy
a tablet for my kid or i should you know
buy a change to a new smartphone
it was thought that indian
consumers would be fascinated by
global products the samsung the google
nexus or the ios and
apple phones and devices
quite surprisingly there have been
become a few indian players who have
competed very aggressively in this
market to the point where samsung is now
losing market share significantly
and this comes about because the way the
supply chain has changed dramatically
the key is often to find what the
consumer needs and to be able to rapidly
innovate
and the wonderful thing about what china
can do and what taiwan can do is you
give them a design in three months it is
produced and available in the retail
shop
so indian companies like micromax carbon
lava etc have been very aggressive
produced very remarkable designs for
example one of the first things and
nokia had a stranglehold on the indian
market it used to be that you went to
india and you you saw everyone using
nokia now nokia is not to be found
and the reason is
the local innovation so the first thing
that uh and i'm not talking feature
phones rather than smartphones one of
the two brothers were standing at a at a
near a tea stall and they saw
a long line of people's
waiting and they were wondering why are
so many people waiting in front of a tea
shop right
turns out that the tea shop provider was
providing
the charging
outlet for
people to charge their phones so they'll
charge it and then go back to their
villages where there is often no power
so what these two brothers came up with
was
to design a phone which had longer
battery power so they took a feature
phone
multiplied you know 2x 3x of battery
power and that absolutely took off and
that was the beginning of micromax
so
at the same time there's another very
interesting thing happening which is
which i call the technology systems are
democratizing democratizing so
we are going from what uh what are
called systems or record to systems of
engagement in systems of record these
are typically
large erp systems they are rigid and
heavy they are enterprise driven
it favors the big entrance players it's
often gated and insular
difficult to integrate to and inside
enterprise data centers so in this world
which
occupied all of us for 25 plus years
it was often difficult to create
something
that could plug into an oracle could
plug into an intuit could plug into an
sap and become big you could do it but
often it did not favor the people who
are far away who are not connected so if
you're in the valley you create an
adapter a tool set a new framework
anywhere you had friends in oracle you
go talk to them absolutely you could do
it but what if you are three guys
sitting
with a buffalo in india can you do it no
you cannot right there is no way you can
provide that kind of
you know coherence to a platform which
is completely sealed off
in contrast we are now moving to systems
of engagement which are flexible light
viral user driven they are occupy they
are in public and private clouds easy to
launch and extend and this now flavor
favors the global entrepreneur
you can launch what you want in the
mobile app store model modular and
federated
and suddenly you can create value at a
distance
that in many case
many cases surprises these guys
they have no clue that these kinds of
values are being created these kinds of
new systems are now available
so the power of this technology system
becoming democratized is that
advantage is now shifted
to the person who is flexible
technology-centric
aggressive willing to take a risk
and put up things on the app store and
see if it works
right
and this is true not just for india for
anywhere in the world it basically has
changed the world upside down in terms
of
defining what is software
so let me go all the way to
two wonderful kids
eleven years and nine years old they
started the company
sanjay became the ceo of the company
he allowed his brother to become the
president
right must have been a lot of
negotiating going on at the dinner table
and
they learned basic c objective c in java
started programming and they started
building mobile apps
wanted to be steve jobs right
and before you
before long they started producing apps
and
started
creating waves
i talked to them this morning
and they said they are building a
low-cost virtual reality device
to compete with oculus rift
and they have a design for google glass
right
look at the power of technology and
once we allow people to communicate what
things what amazing things can happen
so these kids
have published seven apps in the app
store apple app store four in the google
play
they've had 60 000 downloads from 52
countries
and they've been recognized
in india as well as outside
they told me that they participated in
the mit forum in india recently
so amazing kids but it just tells you
that
uh
if you put your mind to it anything can
be done
so
india is changing india is changing very
dynamically
india is changing in ways that are not
apparent
but now let me tell you about things
that have happened recently it's no
longer a coalition government at the
center the recent elections have
produced a government of the full
majority versus the last 10 years where
we had a badly fractured government
which could not take decisions
among the various nations of the world
india is starting to look like an
economic bright spot
uh
growth in china while still positive
looks to be coming down to six to eight
percent which for china is considered
you know depressing
uh the new government has focused on
what they call
minimum bureaucracy maximum governance
so so far indicators are good we'll have
to see make sure that things happen but
india is starting to look better and
better
for the vcs the book values of their
investments are improving and m a's are
starting to happen so all in all things
are looking more cheerful
so i'd argue that india 2015 is the
right place right time
new government no coalition strong focus
on governance the technology has been
democratized this is happening obviously
on a global level
and global entrepreneurship is being
unleashed
in india there's a very strong
technology base there are a lot of
millions uh you know
a couple million people who understand
technology because they've been serving
they've worked at ibm global services
they worked for cognizant infosys and
numerous other players and as a
consequence
the familiarity with technology is
extremely good
and there are wonderful success stories
to prove that it is possible to become a
billionaire using you know being an
entrepreneur
at the same time the economy is starting
to improve quite dramatically
a billion plus mobile users
inbound fdi
and
most importantly
indians are buying through m-commerce
at a rate which is amazingly surprising
let me talk to you also about things
which are inherently domestic
just like china has there are
compelling companies which are chinese
china-centric which is difficult for
an external person to crack there are a
few indian things that indian
entrepreneurs have cracked
which are illustrative of the way things
work
let me first talk and the word desi
means indian
let me first talk to you about this
company called just dial
just dial is the equivalent of google
search
and the way it works is as follows you
don't need a smartphone you just call a
number
i think it is
triple eight eight eight eight eight or
something like that you call that number
there are 8 000 agents standing by
and they have essentially all the yellow
pages at hand digitized
so you call up and say
mountain view pizza
they can immediately ensure that an sms
comes to you
from a particular mountain view pizza
place
and that comes because they have
listings
they have about
12 million listings of our businesses in
india
every city every neighborhood
they are then able to rank it just like
google ranks it the highest guy gets to
the highest slot
and therefore when you say pizza
mountain view that top guy who has paid
the most in terms of the advertising
slot gets the shot
they're making a fair amount of money
they're a public company
and
profitable
ah thank you
so that's just dial
let me come to zip dial which is even
more interesting
indians hate to pay for things okay
now in india unlike the us
when
you make a call you pay money when you
receive uh
a call you don't
so indians don't like to make the call
and pay for it even though cell phone
rates are dropping dramatically so they
invented this thing called a missed call
so let us say i
drop off my wife at the bus stop
and she
i want to know that she has reached work
safely when she reaches work she gives
me a call
but i don't pick up the phone
i realize that it's a message to me
saying i've reached that's why she's
called
so she would call and terminate the call
right
so that messaging system obviously has
value
so a lady i think a stanford graduate
valerie wagoner who lived in india
she and another person called sanjay
swami started talking how do we use this
phenomenon right is there value to this
behavior
and they realized yes there is there is
a lot of potential so this is what they
created
they went to a lot of advertisers and
said
we will give you unique zip dial numbers
right
you then popularize these zip dial
numbers in various places in contests in
bus stops and so on
so let's say i am an air conditioner
manufacturer so when i on my holding
i'll say
zip dial
this number
when that number is zip dialed there is
no cost to the caller
instead that number
goes through the network and is captured
as a mobile caller
with a looking for a referral on this
particular item
that is then translated to a line for
further communications so that
manufacturer let's say the air
conditioner would then be able to send
an sms back
and increasingly with smartphones other
ways of
providing information which says hi i
understand you're interested in air
conditioner we have 20 off this month
our shop is located here
so now you've opened up a channel and
all of this now is captured through
analytics
this has become an amazingly cheap way
to
launch campaigns for large companies and
the beauty of it is customer opt-in is
inherent in this process
right
red bus
there were three
people working in bangalore
one of whom wanted to get to hyderabad
which is a city about a couple hundred
miles away
and he rushed from one
bus transporter to another but could not
find a bus to get home
india is a very poorly structured road
transport market a lot of operators not
enough visibility on how much how many
seats are available how to uh you know
get to those seats et cetera so often
you have to get to the bus stop or the
terminal and hope for the best
these guys have organized this
they are now
created a system where they have
rationalized it there are 30 000 red bus
outlets
1500 bus operators use them 80 000
routes are being served
mobile phones
based reservations etc
a dramatic simplification of how you can
take a very unstructured
poorly organized system and make it
organized
and finally we come to india's
fascination
with marriage
right
of course there are of course a lot of
people we need to get 100 plus million
people married on a regular basis so
it's a non-trivial problem right
now
the issue is
when i was growing up there are only
three c's now that i understand there
are six seas the three c's were cast
carrier and cash
okay
uh
cash was more not from the uh
brides bright groom side it was often
for the bright side so india had a dowry
system and all those things
a lot of those things are going away but
let me come to the six c's that they saw
okay you have to choose your companion
in a western society you choose it by
a reference system
dating system meet in colleges etc all
those things are not as easily available
to the hundreds of millions in india now
so what do they do they go to shaadi.com
and a variety of other players like that
and they look for success compatibility
chemistry commitment community
communication and compassion
now if these were there when my wife
married me no i might not have gotten
married
right
so anyhow they've done
quite a remarkable job in creating an
industry
let me come to
the david versus goliath stories
these are plays where
people
large companies from typically from the
us
want to come into the indian economy
and be a giant
now these are not difficult to overcome
i mean these are very difficult to
overcome and
indian players have tried to match
themselves against that so let me talk
about the first one flipkart this is
indian ecommerce trying to be an amazon
2014 sales of about 3 billion the
company is valued about 7 billion
july 29th of this year
they got funding of 1 billion
from gic and tiger global gic is a
singapore based
fund
amazon comes in
it's all doing a billion already in
india
valued at 144 billion minus
8 or so today
something like that
and the day after it was announced that
they got a billion jeff bezos came and
said but i'm putting in 2 billion into
amazon india just to let you guys know
right
so this is going to be an interesting
battle
and obviously big investors are betting
that an indian local player
can
match their wits against amazon
the second is snapdeal which is an
amazon plus groupon model sales about a
billion
it has received 100 million from temasek
earlier this year
matching itself against groupon
groupon has not done well in india they
entered india they goofed up they left
they are now back we'll have to see how
it plays out
how much they put in india is not known
but one interesting thing is they had
what is called the
the
great onion
discount
and onions in india are extraordinarily
popular
and there was a time when there was an
onion crisis
not enough onions in the land
and so
groupon said this is the opportunity
let's buy up a lot of onions and have
the great onion sale unfortunately when
they did they didn't count on the fact
that onions are extremely popular and
immediately the groupon servers in india
crashed
so
so if you're going to do the onion sale
make sure you protect your servers
finally uber
uber is obviously relatively new even
for us right
three plus years here
and
what i was surprised by i was in india
recently is
uber in india works quite well so they
have come rapidly into the indian market
and set up a series of operators
so i asked an operator how do you get to
uber he said
in india there are a lot of taxis who
are owner-owned so they just they called
them up and they attended a three-hour
program they said this is an iphone
and uh this is a locked system all you
have to do is switch it on it comes on
to uber
right and you can't do anything else
with it
this is how you operate it
let me check your car let me check your
license you are now a uber driver
right within hours they had created
uber drivers
quite a remarkable entry point into
india the nice thing for them is india
is not as organized as france germany
new york so the objections to an uber
are relatively low
right works amazingly well i was very
impressed one of the even more
impressive is
the local player is copying an uber
immediately
so he's got hola cabs
he's got funding he's got you know a
reasonable valuation and he's able to
operate equally well
so here you see that this tussle
is on relatively equal footing and this
comes from technology being democratized
right
if i see your business model and i know
how to do it i can replicate your
app
as well as you know you create it i will
replicate it in some cases i will go
better than you
so that is
a perspective of how india is changing
i'm going to give you a few case studies
of companies that i know better
e dreams is a company that is looking at
the education market
india needs to educate some 500 million
plus people
so
india is a relatively young country
what this company is trying to attack is
what they call the learning deficit uh
the teacher which is true equally here
often teaches to the median
is unable to teach to the spectrum
because there might be some students who
are racing ahead of the class some
students who are lagging
what does the poor teacher do
he or she tries to teach to the middle
now unfortunately that doesn't do
justice to any of them what this
software tries to do is to say let me
look at your potential to learn let me
understand your deficit and create a
personalized learning experience for you
so
the company there has an engine patent
pending based on artificial indust
intelligence and
machine learning it's deployed today for
uh grades two to eight so they've done
it in uh
for fifty thousand plus students hundred
plus schools
fairly profitable the way the work the
system is they tell the they show the
principal and the teachers that
if you're if you adopt our system your
students can learn at home this is the
software to learn about how well you're
doing how well the child is doing and
automatically start giving it more
quizzes more questions on the right
areas etcetera
so
good uh sales traction good funding the
company is on its way
here's another company called wooker
wooker uh is a company that indus age
has invested in
and we think of this to be a remarkable
global company
what does worker do
hookup empowers the end user
in terms of performing a variety of
enterprise functions so we have created
enterprise software over the last 25-30
years in terms of
financials manufacturing supply chain
e-commerce
you know crm etc
and then you have some social media
which has got functionality which is
often external to these uh
these kinds of softwares or you have
dedicated software like sharepoint or
salesforce
what vucker says is i can provide most
of the things that these platforms do
in ways that you want but and you do it
yourself
you create the orchestration that is
relevant for your company dynamically
versus accept the orchestration that is
inbuilt inside an oracle erp or an sap
erp
so that kind of flexibility changes the
outcomes so
here's a when i was talking to the ceo
here's an example that he gave me so let
us say there is
there are
large franchised shops let's say
mcdonald's starbucks etc
now the structure of these things is is
that the centralized functions
procurement in our revenues
employee management etc is managed
through an erp systems
but think of things like placards bulbs
you know exit signs
who manages those what enterprise system
would manage those kinds of things the
reality is those are minor things in
some financial uh spreadsheet right
to tackle those kinds of things is
extraordinarily difficult ex yet it is
terribly important
in a worker it is easy to do and that
allows you to tackle things like let me
set up a system for management of all
bulbs in the country in the company
right and so when you know that there is
a bulb which is gone out
you get a signal which says okay 20 000
bulbs have gone out need to be replaced
that cause can have a trigger to
procurement
so those kinds of systems easy
enablement of enterprise orchestration
is what wuka does so
here are the set of possibilities for
sales resource management customer
feedback
learning employee engagement
skills assessment human resources hiring
town halls
products new product demonstrations
sales training motivation customer
history service catalogs
operation scorecards compliance licenses
any of these things can be orchestrated
and managed through the wooker platform
so it has turned out to be quite a
powerful system
gaining a lot of traction
300 almost 400 000 users
3 200 use cases
9.2 million
hours of usage
small team
a lot of functionality built in
and already a profitable company
so we are very
pleased to see the evolution of booker
going from a lot of indian
environments
to now increasingly global
they've done marx and spencer in uk
there are they are
attacking to
uh
good organizations good large
organizations in the us as well as in
europe
so that's wooker
let me talk to you about another company
which is
also fascinating
in india
electricity is a is a huge problem
while there are urban and semi-urban
grids
rural electricity is actually quite
challenged
what this company did and these are two
uh
couple of founders
who are not indian
they saw the problem in india they
settled in india and started
working on
it annoying expensive and lousy energy
is what a lot of indians have
one points
globally 1.6 billion with no electricity
people spend on kerosene
candles batteries
and obviously it's an extraordinarily
frustrating environment but there's in
most indian villages
most uh
huts there's no light after dark
kids can't study uh
difficult to cook
mosquitoes can be annoying etc
so what this company did
was to look at a solution which consists
of
a solar cell
a cell phone based orchestration of
demand
and then a simple management
panel
how does it work it works on a prepaid
system
so here's a kit
you you get the kit along with the panel
and you then power your devices with it
you put in a small down payment
and then you get prepaid energy credits
so you consume what you pay for
and
with
your cell phone yes using an sms based
system you can unlock more credits based
on your payment
so they've created a platform software
as a service based platform uh the back
end of it uh manages the customer
request and the revenue management
there's an integrated meter
which is
part of the system that the user has
so the user
takes this kit and uses it at home so
typically it's a 40 watt panel and it's
able to power a few things and the
interesting thing they found was
that
rural users are extremely sophisticated
about how to use this so they would
switch on
the lights for the kids to study
rather than switching on the fan they
would you know
minimize the usage based on their income
levels or the income patterns and so on
and this is funded by a variety of
entities uh
asian development bank coastline impact
etc
so
once again coming along quite
the grid well
it's an independent system yes it's
independent standalone you have to buy
it and maintain the kit
so let me now get to the summary
i believe that india is leapfrogging to
a new market economy of a kind that we
may not have seen elsewhere in the world
this is a different game
there are 1 billion people who are
fundamentally mobile connected and now
starting to consume products and
services
in many ways literacy is not a
requirement for e-commerce
that's what indian consumers are saying
infrastructure is good in india and
governance is improving
the economic signals
for india are broadly positive
certainly in comparison to most parts of
the world
foreign and domestic investors are
engaged in investing
entrepreneurs in india are technically
advantaged there are a lot of them and
they are very passionate
there are demonstrable success stories
that
show that indian entrepreneurs can
create domestic and global globally
significant companies
so india 2015 and beyond it's the right
place right time
thank you
you know rich content presentation can i
ask uh to start with
what is your distinction between
creating value and just creating revenue
can you explain that a little bit more
how you want to differentiate those two
so
let me hop back to what india has done
well
india had the fortune of
having a relatively
large pool of
educated people particularly engineering
the heritage of the british and
subsequent evolution
has left india with a lot of very good
engineering institutions
and it is often true that engineers
indians aspired to be educated so
the push to become an engineer and or a
doctor in india was very high
india therefore created
arguably a lot more engineers than it
could consume these then became the
assets for
particularly the us
so
and the more engineers that were and of
course things like y2k revolution
development of erp the sas world etc
certainly argued for more and more
engineering to be done in some cases to
be done here
in many cases to be done
in
development development centers
of foreign companies in india or to be
done as outsourcing through ibm global
services accenture infosys cognizant
vipro etc
so this combination produced
a very large bench of talent right
and there was this
possibly because of the h-1b system
visa issues constant flow between india
to the u.s and back so this sloshing of
go to the u.s do
two or three year projects learn come
back to india
maybe go back again so there is constant
going back and forth produced has
produced
anything from one to two million people
who are now quite sophisticated in their
understanding of technology but these
were by and large what i would call
brains on a stick
very smart people who know a lot of
things
but their value is if you will singular
right
so that singularity of value means that
i'm charging for this person
versus charging for a product that has
been created
now the great thing about what american
companies often do is to create enduring
products so oracle creates a product
having invested two years
you know 100 people on the on the
product suddenly that has got a lifetime
of 10 years 15 years right by and large
indian companies had failed to do that
now what is changing now is that
creation of values now occurring in
india both for usage in india as well as
usage globally and that's what i mean by
creation of value okay thanks that helps
let's open the floor to questions
what's the local view in terms of uh
like the facebooks and googles and how
they're trying to connect
uh people around the world through
drones or balloons uh what's the
sentiment locally for those types of
initiatives
that google or facebook could provide
through alternate methods like these
balloons and drones etc
i don't think indians think of facebook
and google as providing those kinds of
services yet in india there's obviously
no tangible proof
uh that it could be done
but
they are among the most voluminous users
of these two companies products right
whether it is gmail or facebook i think
the second largest population of
facebook users i think is in india
right
interestingly enough
just after this new government took over
uh this is prime minister modi
in the last three months
jeff bezos has been has met him
zuckerberg has met him
uh
from senior i don't know someone from i
think sundar pichai met him from google
so all these players are there because
they realize that
india can change their outcomes
and what i understand the prime minister
told zukerberg is
health
i want your help in having facebook
improve the quality of life and outcomes
for india
so apparently zuckerberg has taken that
on as a mission in terms of how to
produce social outcomes
in terms of economic socioeconomic
benefit
okay
thank you uh down front you had a
question uh yeah what are the
demographics like
startup entrepreneurs are there
from undergrad or older
experience
this is not or what
if i look at
this is changing quite dramatically it
used to be the oldies it used to be
people who have been here gone back got
money now i'm going to do uh you know a
startup to now kids who are graduating
from
an engineering institution saying i want
to do a startup
um so i
judge some of these competitions i've
been in many of these uh festivals kind
of thing
i would say the average age is probably
now
26 to 30.
it's typically two or three guys who
have
or gals who have been together in a
college
um the entrepreneur bug has bit them
i'll tell you one key thing which is
happening they have now realized
particularly in the software industry
is
there is practically no risk to doing so
there is i.t there are i.t jobs always
available they could
at any time say
heck my startup is not working and they
would find a job in an infosys or a
symantec or on you know facebook etc in
fact they also realize that failure is
actually good
to be able to say i tried a startup
we did this that and the other
and it's all right i gave up and now i'm
ready to work
so this ability to say that i can take
risk which is very true of why silicon
valley succeeds
i am willing to take risk with my
profession with my career because i know
that risk is not it does not have a
consequence of
my career is short i i'm taking a
financial risk but i make it up by
getting experience so that has started
to happen and that has released the
pent-up
passions
of a lot of people entrepreneurs
today i wanted to ask you about your
thoughts on the rationale behind many
global investors investing in companies
like flipkart and myntra where they are
not profitable at this moment
but that only him seems to be increasing
the user base
and since given the
consumer is pretty elastic let's say if
snapdeal is giving more discount he will
immediately move to snapdead so there's
no sort of attachment to a given brand
amazon or flipkart what do you think why
do you think investors are betting big
on
these companies when someone with use
money like amazon can just
enter the market and take over there
it's a simple game the game is the same
game that amazon is playing
right why does amazon do what it's doing
amazon is an amazingly unprofitable
company
right
it's just i mean even the latest results
say so right it's a very large company
its revenues are huge and growing quite
dramatically its profitability is
laser thin or negative right
but what amazon is doing is got a
profound logic
which is if i am the dominant player
customers will automatically come to me
so today there's no question that if you
want to buy a book you'll go to amazon
in fact most things you would go to
amazon and it's because jeff bezos has
repeatedly invested in saying let me get
that customer mind share so that they
believe that i am the game in town
in the indian marketplace we are at a
very early stage of the devolution
the mind share capture is ridiculously
small
so customers are saying sure snap deal
gives me a better deal i'm going there
but they will play the game and these
guys have to figure it out in terms of a
lot more money and a lot more traction
to demonstrate that they deserve that
support right
so
it's a game that has to be fought you
know uh and we'll never see two three
key players emerge out of that
so
i wanna i wanna
candidate for all the bigger companies
as well that's one of the reasons like
you know though they are making big loss
like you know they tend to uh promote a
lot of things and get their customer
base uh set so they might be required
yeah yeah i think mantra was just a flip
card right i want to follow up on this
too because last week in our
presentation you know uh xiao mentioned
that there are 1300
uh groupon lookalikes in china right so
uh in
in that system continue you continue to
have
a lot of very small competitors who
persist
whereas in the u.s once two or three
companies become dominant other people
kind of move away from that space
you know unless they really do it in a
noticeably different way
how does india fit into that spectrum do
you see the kind of pattern of
consolidation that you do here the
acquisition
so let's look at uh the retail
environment
let's look at the way retail evolved so
we all started out with a lot of local
stores many of which we are familiar
with we would walk by drive by and say
okay i will go to this
entity for
my clothes and that entity for my shoes
etc
and at some point we got the evolution
of big box stores right and you had the
concept of malls and you said okay sears
is in that corner and jcpenney is in
that corner now you say okay i can go to
one place and get everything that i want
right and for that to accrue that
advantage sears and pennies and others
had to spend a lot to say let me get
that mind share and i can get you all
the things that you need in one place
and you know satisfy your needs right
in many ways online is repeating that so
we're going to have players who
a
lot of little players are going to say
but but why not me right and people will
experiment and if they get a better deal
absolutely they'll choose that but
they're also going to say but is this
person this entity trustworthy
are they reliable will they actually
deliver to me and this is where i think
the presence of an amazon etc starts to
blow away the competition they say
amazon known for delivery guaranteed
quality there is you know i can return
the product if i don't like it
a smaller player may not be able to
guarantee those things so the customer
is constantly checking validating
verifying so for certain kinds of
transactions they'll go to the name
brand if it's ad hoc you know
there's no consequence to making the
selection they would make the alternate
selection and so on but it's a game
very early in its uh in its play
the winners are you know
uh as likely to be today's players or
new ones so that come along
okay thanks
so in that regard what do you think is
going to happen with the david and
goliath stories
if i had to guess
amazon
would become dominant in india
uh
assuming that they buy out flip card or
his flipkart too big they did offer to
buy out flipkart i think they gave them
a billion dollar valuation and flipkart
they declined it
flipkart is now being funded by
relatively serious players who see that
this is a market worth fighting for but
i think amazon will come out number one
i think in the second case the dynamics
of indian buyer sellers may be a little
bit complicated for groupon to manage so
in that case i would argue that snapdeal
has got an advantage
but i also suspect snapkey is a snapdeal
could be bought out
the third game which is uh voila cabs
was uber
i think uh
there's good likelihood that ola would
give a uber a run for its money maybe
become the avis to a hurts but uh
it's not clear who is and who's
okay kind of following up on that um
you know we're seeing some of the
recently
some of the chinese companies that have
recently become huge like
huawei and these companies really going
global right alibaba
listing itself in the u.s
so
infosys and wipro were years ago when
they really went global
and do you see any of these new
companies like flipkart
really trying to compete on in markets
outside india really going global
outside there
um i think
flipkart kind of companies
currently at least i think are india
centric india focused because it
requires a lot of logistics in order to
make that happen and they might not have
the wherewithal to fight a global battle
where i see indian companies advantaged
are companies who have created
like a wooker
who have very transportable uh value
where it the globalization doesn't have
on the ground logistics operations yeah
and i think uh a lot of indian companies
could be advantaged in that play
okay
uh
one more question kind of on the
incubation side in your presentation it
sort of looked like there was a wave of
government incubators before the angels
came in then the angels came in and
suddenly we didn't hear about incubation
stories and not so true i would say the
tendency of
government institutions which may be
true even of the u.s is it's easy to set
up these kinds of facilities
and then
there is very little governance as
governance associated with the utility
of them yeah so they continue on for an
endless period of time
um
whereas vcs are quick to change they see
things don't work
and
they change their pattern of lending
they change the stage at which they
invest they change the amount and as a
consequence they are able to dynamically
differentiate
and discriminate between how to create
value i would argue that government
should
be less in the incubation business and
be more in
making sure the economy functions better
at that level
but for a variety of circumstances
obviously all governments put some money
into you know
making these kinds of facilities
available okay great brother
let's follow up that question again
how many of those incubator centers are
still alive
because they went away
in fact more incubators are starting up
um
very large ones even without too much
results
so i think
the see the results are often indirect
so i should not be so negative
see some of these things so you could
ask for instance what is the value of a
school why doesn't the school produce
geniuses but the reality is the school
has to graduate these kids and maybe
they will become gnss after some time so
in some sense incubators also
have that function which is let me groom
a future entrepreneur
and there's no harm in that as long as
the government sees that as a part of
its financial portfolio to fulfill
so there are a lot of them still alive i
would say more are coming and it
provides a training ground for a lot of
entrepreneurs
so they start thinking of i need to
create a business plan i need to find my
team i need to be able to speak well i
need to be able to articulate a value
proposition i need to create something
all those things do happen in incubators
that they do not become
very valuable companies
is one aspect of what you can say that
is a failure it is true but it's also
true that there is success in a
different dimension
even companies like citrix are starting
their implications in india and they are
starting their program in india so there
are a lot of uh y combinator kind of
thing is coming up in
the two categories i would say one is
like b to c and you know b to b to b
like you know these are two kinds of
segments which is happening right now
okay two last questions back in the back
first okay
what can
india learn from the silicon valley
experience
and what can silicon valley learn from
india
i would say they are learning from each
other already a lot of silicon valley
is many ways has got indian influence in
it in terms of companies being created
uh ceos ctos engineering etc so a lot of
great companies here have indian dna in
it a lot of that learning has
transmitted itself to india so if you
visit bangalore you'll see the dynamic
of bangalore is in many ways similar to
silicon valley not all the artifacts are
there but there are there is enough now
to have an ecosystem which is quite
powerful
what can the us learn from india
the reality is the world is changing and
it may be that
structures in the u.s are not changing
fast enough
it's inevitable that
successful systems tend to hold on to
things that work
right so we are sitting on i would argue
30 40 years of legacy software now in
this country those are not as a
as
user-centric as some of the new software
that is being created so let me give you
an illustration
india is in its early stages of i would
argue governance
governance in india is relatively
primitive citizen contract is poor
but the new government says here is my
gov dot in
i want you as a citizen to sign in and i
want to communicate to you directly you
can now find x y and z about the way my
government functions
right this is true of the way the
railway system is being set up you know
instantaneously
it's a huge bureaucracy but it still
functions quite well because it is set
up with a new thought in mind which is
inherently
user-centric inherently web-based mobile
based inherently connectable for end
users to use the system
legacy systems on the other hand have a
hard time jump making that leap
what they try to do is to adapt they say
here is
rigid legacy software let me create a
mobile version of it
now that mobile version unfortunately
has got the trappings of the legacy
environment
right so we have got that in the u.s you
take our healthcare system
amazingly primitive in many ways and we
struggle to put up a healthcare system
which says i a citizen should have
access to my records
right so india in many ways is creating
a new economy built on much more robust
technology foundations but the journey
is has just begun
that god could only
create the world in six days because
there was no legacy issues
it would seem to me you know based on
things that i've read uh based on your
presentation and other people have met
indian
startups seem to have a really great
advantage in developing worlds or
emerging markets models because they
live it
even if you are very well educated and
even if you're in a city or a town with
good infrastructure there are people all
around you don't have that
so could you comment a little bit about
you know the fact that uh and a good
example would be last year in your class
you had a company that was doing mobile
search yeah over feature phones
brilliant who here would think of doing
that
nobody carries around those phones over
here could you comment about that
advantage a bit because africa is
growing like mad right now correct
let me answer that question um
in a roundabout way
some of you might have heard of
something called mom
it's the mars orbiter that india
developed right
now
mars orbiter worked the following way
unlike
the system that nasa developed
it did not
put too much emphasis on its powering
stages
instead what it did was it focused it
used earth's gravity to propel itself
so
the mars orbiter
went around the earth several times
as a consequence it now generated more
and more
velocity
and at some point it used it released
itself on the earth's orbit so it
catapulted itself
using gravity as a mechanism of
propulsion
onto a mars orbit
then it secured the mars orbit and is
now
providing great photographs this is a
good analogy to what's happening to
indian companies
so indian companies are like the mars
orbiters they don't have much
financial power unlike u.s companies
but what they are doing i would think
smartly is to say let me first orbit
around india
let me validate the indian business
model make sure i can get customers i
can get traction refine my orbiter
once i've secured that
i now launch myself to get traction
in the u.s u.s is a clear trajectory u.s
is the mars for indian companies
so they then come to the u.s
and secure the orbit and hopefully get
acquired or go ipo
so that's a model
of traction in india
you know exit in the u.s the reason it
works is india is a sufficiently large
economy
it's not so small that you cannot
experiment all these business models are
available people have mobile phones
people have access connectivity is
dramatically better people have
propensity to spend and therefore you
can validate your business models right
in the new market economy in the new
technology democratized technology that
i talked about as a consequence you
validate those
now you're able you're ready for africa
you're ready for europe you're ready for
the u.s
siri
i want to join you again join everybody
thanks very much for a great
presentation
you